pas les supporteurs du psg qui
évidemment ont fait la fête hier soir à
paris sur les champs elysées ambiance
beaucoup plus morose à marseille
globalement pour cette rencontre à haut
risque pas d'incident majeur tout de
même une quarantaine d'interpellations
avant le début du match philippe
visseyrias christian galley les champs
elysées aux couleurs du paris saint
germain dès la fin du match ils sont
plusieurs centaines à converger place de
l'étoile
une joie bon enfant pas de casse pas
d'affrontement
les supporters du psg simplement heureux
d'avoir vaincu leurs meilleurs ennemis
vous ont fait de doute et toute la
saison mais quand même c'était la plus
belle chose qui pouvait nous autant la
victoire la victoire et la coupe brandie
au coeur de paris il est alors 1h30 du
matin à l'hôtel de ville et le maire
bertrand delanoë résume le sentiment
général
du côté marseillais silence de plomb à
la sortie du stade de france
autour des trente mille fans de l'om un
dispositif policier impressionnant a
permis de limiter les affrontements
bilan quelques blessés trente et une
garde à vue et robert pitte lgv
direction marseille est toujours le même
silence
au petit matin c'est la gueule de bois
personnellement on souhaite difficile en
question
même désillusion pour ceux qui sont
restés à marseille pourtant ils sont des
milliers au stade vélodrome devant un
écran géant ou dans les cafés sur le
vieux-port déplorable nous refuse de
[ __ ] sur la première mi temps
qu'est ce qu'on voulait qu'on fasse
cette coupe ils la voyaient déjà à
marseille leur déception n'en est que
plus forte